Wow Isis is on the brink of losing its
last bit of territory in Syria the u.s.
is also helping battle another terror
threat in West Africa jihadist push out
of pushed out of Iraq and Syria are
going to Africa and escalating violence
there the u.s. is training West African
forces in the country of Burkina Faso to
fight back but US military cuts could
leave the region vulnerable first on CBS
this morning Debora patta takes us
inside the training program we blurred
some soldiers faces for their security
there is an eerie familiarity to this
training exercise West African soldiers
creep stealthily along the wall of a
hotel in Burkina Faso inside all hell
breaks loose the soldiers are being
trained by US Special Forces to storm a
hotel under attack by Islamic extremists
it's not real but could so easily be a
scene played out with alarming frequency
in West Africa akina Faso has become the
epicenter for violent extremists
bolstered by trained jihadists returning
from Iraq and Syria now there's a stream
of trained fighters who are coming from
that region they need someplace to go
Major General Marcus Hicks says the
focus on Isis has created an opportunity
for other terror groups al Qaeda has
been able to take advantage of the
attention being paid to the Middle East
while they quietly build infrastructure
and support here in Africa although the
violence is surging the u.s. is reducing
its footprint in Africa the Trump
administration has already trimmed
budgets by 10 percent with another cut
in the world but this training is seen
as crucial for both the security of the
region and the u.s. if we can help them
try and eliminate the threat here now
why it's small then it won't spread to
Europe it won't spread to the United
States eventually the CBS this morning
Debora patta Waga dugu burkina faso